القليل من الفضول دفعنا لسؤال ذكاء
الاصطناعي نفسه من خلال تشاد عن كيفيه
انقراض البشريه
نفى قدرته كذكاء الصناعي على التنبؤ دقيق
بمستقبل البشريه لكنه طرح سيناريوهات
محتمله وصادمه لانقراضنا كبشر اولها الحرب
النوويه واسعه النطاق ثانيها الكوارث
البيئيه وثالثها الاوبئه والامراض لكن
الاخطر بين اجاباته كان الكوارث
التكنولوجيه وهنا قال ان خطا بشريا او
فشلا بالتكنولوجيا الحديثه قد يؤدي
الانهيار الانظمه الحاسوبيه الحيويه
وبالتالي القضاء على البشريه
فسالنا تشاد جي بي تي السؤال الابرز كيف
يمكن للذكاء الاصطناعي ان يقضي على
البشريه التطبيق الذكي وخلافا لسرعته
المعتاده بالاجابه والتي لا تتعدى ثواني
استلزمه اكثر من خمس دقائق قبل بتلاقي
بدلوه وقال ان ذكاء الاصطناعي بحد ذاته
ليس مهددا للبشريه بل هو مجرد اداه تعتمد
على كيفيه استخدامها وتصميمها وختم اجابته
بشعار لديك عطل في الشبكه الانترنت اعدنا
السؤال باصرار فاضطر لتعداد السيناريوهات
يمكن وصفها بالمخيفه اولها التمكن الذاتي
اي حين يتمكن ذكاء الاصطناعي من تطوير
نفسه بنفسه باستمرار وبمعدلات هائله وقد
يتحكم في مصائر البشريه بطرق لا يمكن
للبشر ان يتنافسوا معها اما السيناريو
الثاني وعلى ذمه تشاد هو عدم التفاهم بين
ما يعتبره ذكاء للصناعي الافضل للبشريه
وبينما يعتبره البشر الافضل لانفسهم وهنا
تتصادم وتتعارض المصالح وربما تهدد
البشريه اخر السيناريوهات السيطره الشامله
حين يحقق الذكاء الاصطناعي سيطره كامله
على النظم الحاسوبيه والانظمه الاخرى في
العالم مثل بنيه الحكومات وبالتالي يمكنه
قمع البشريه او تدميرها بشكل كامل لم
نستطع تخطي مساله صغراقه وقتا طويلا
للاجابه سالناه عن السبب لياتي الرد ان
السؤال يتعامل مع مساله جديه ومعقده تتعلق
بالحياه البشريه وبمستقبلنا ولا يمكن
التجاوب معها بسطحيه
[موسيقى]
اسوا مخاوف هو ان نسبب نحن اي قطاع الذكاء
الاصطناعي اذيه كبيره للعالم اعتقد ان ذلك
قد يحصل بطرق مختلفه في حال حدوث اي خطا
بهذه التقنيه فقد تذهب باتجاه سيء للغايه
نريد ان نكون صريحين بشان ذلك ونريد ان
نعمل مع الحكومه لمنع ذلك من الحصول
ونحاول ان نكون يقظين حول الاثار السلبيه
وما يمكننا فعله لمعالجه ذلك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات